nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui monsieur lucrimont qui est
le candidat proposé par le Président de
la République aux fonctions de président
directeur général du groupe EDF c'est
évidemment un poste et une mission
extrêmement importante et pour laquelle
notre commission évidemment est très
attentive je vous rappelle que cette
nomination ne peut pas ne peut
intervenir qu'après audition devant les
commissions compétentes et de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat cette
audition est publique elle est ouverte à
la presse et elle est retransmise sur
notre site Internet et donc je salue à
la fois bien sûr les journalistes mais
j'en suis sûr les salariés d'EDF qui
doivent être à l'écoute de cette
audition elle sera suivie d'un vote qui
se déroulera je vous le rappelle aussi à
bulletin secret et je rappelle que les
délégations de vote ne sont pas
autorisées donc ceux qui seront présents
citron uniquement
et je vous rappelle que le dépouillement
doit être effectué simultanément avec
l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale en tendant Monsieur Raymond
après nous nous dépouillerons les
bulletins à la mi-journée en application
du cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de
la Constitution le président de la
République ne pourrait procéder à votre
nomination Monsieur Raymond si
l'addition des votes négatifs exprimés
dans les deux assemblées représentaient
au moins 3/5 des suffrages exprimés
avant de passer la parole à notre
collègue Daniel grimillet qui est
président du groupe d'études énergie et
rapporteur sur cette nomination je
souhaiterais rappeler solennellement ici
la gravité de la crise énergétique que
nous traversons la guerre russe en
Ukraine a évidemment une incidence
considérable sur le marché gazier et par
voie de conséquence sur celui de
l'électricité en raison du principe du
coup marginal qui les lient de plus
notre production d'électricité nucléaire
est au plus bas nous en reparlerons avec
une perspective de moins de 300 tt pour
2022 contenu du phénomène désormais bien
connu de corrosion sous contrainte qui a
touché 30 réacteur je rappelle que nous
avons été la première instance
parlementaire à évoquer directement et
précocement ce sujet ainsi que ses
implications sur notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement en février dès
février dans le cas de des Tavaux de
notre collègue précisément de Daniel
grimillet de Jean-Pierre Moga et de
Jean-Jacques Michaud dans ce contexte
très dégradé on peut noter les
hésitations du gouvernement c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire on légifère
dans le désordre on l'a dit et redit
plusieurs fois dans cette commission et
dans et dans notre assemblée alors qu'il
aurait fallu commencer par la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
nous donner le cap puis par les j'allais
dire les éléments de de d'exécution nous
avons commencé à le projet de loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables ne comportait pas jusqu'à
hier soir de disposition sur les drôles
électricité qui est pourtant notre
première source d'énergie renouvelable
et la présentation au Conseil des
ministres du projet d'accélération de
l'énergie nucléaire qui nous intéresse
beaucoup a été reportée laissant en
suspens la relance de cette filière
annoncée en février dernier mais aussi
avant les élections présidentielles en
octobre de l'année dernière enfin nous
sommes dans le flou s'agissant de notre
cap énergétique l'objectif de réduction
de 50% de notre production nucléaire la
fermeture de 12 réacteurs au-delà de
ceux de Fessenheim et temps je vous le
rappelle mes chers collègues toujours
inscrits dans la loi et dans le
règlement ça me paraît un peu ubuesque
ce manque de cap est aussi palpable dans
les relations entre le gouvernement et
le groupe EDF donc je viens au groupe
EDF qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui votre
prédécesseur Jean-Bernard Lévy a été mis
publiquement en cause par le Président
de la République le 6 septembre dernier
sur donc d'anticipation de la relance du
nucléaire en particulier pour permettre
aux opérateurs économiques d'anticiper
c'est au pouvoir politique de leur
donner le cap et force est de constater
au-delà des effets d'annonce que le
gouvernement a beaucoup louvoyé nous
l'avons dit dans une lettre ouverte
c'est d'ailleurs avec notre collègue
Daniel grimmiel et le gouvernement a
multiplié les décisions qui nous
semblent défavorables au groupe EDF la
fermeture des réacteurs de Fessenheim en
mars et juin 2020 c'est 1,8 gigawatts et
2000 emplois directs qui sont concernés
le relèvement de la reine en février
2022 c'est 10 milliards d'euros autant
de moyens en moins alors que le groupe
est grevé je le rappelle d'une dette de
43 milliards d'euros est confronté à un
mur d'investissement pour relancer le
nucléaire et accélérer le renouvelable
l'équation est donc très complexe et la
nationalisation du groupe très flou
et ça à notre avis ne règle rien du tout
à défaut d'action gouvernementale notre
commission a geler le plafond de la
reine à son interawatt-heure relever son
montant à 49
du mégawater non sans difficulté 49,50 €
pardon dans le cadre du projet de loi de
protection sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
donc une question à laquelle nous sommes
très attentifs voilà mesurer mon le
contexte dans lequel vous arrivez qui
est un contexte de crise un contexte
d'urgence avec une conjoncture chaotique
et des chantiers titanesques voilà si
votre nomination est confirmée par le
Parlement vous seriez en quelque sorte
un capitaine en pleine tempête voilà mes
dotées il est vrai il me semble d'une
solide expérience nous avions auditionné
votre prédécesseur à six reprises ces
dernières années je ne doute pas que
nous serons appelés à nous revoir en cas
de confirmation voilà voilà pour le
contexte général et avant de vous
laisser répondre je vais donner la
parole à Daniel grimillac qui va vous
poser les premières questions
merci Madame un présidente mes chers
collègues Monsieur Raymond l'audition
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui et tout sauf
formel
au contraire elle est éminemment
stratégique l'enjeu est de redonner un
cap au groupe EDF dans la situation de
crise énergétique et de la dette
financière rappelée par notre présidente
ce cap il sera déterminant pour relancer
le nucléaire et accélérer le
renouvelable mais Monsieur Raymond il va
plus loin parce que ce cap il sera
déterminant sur le fait que les ménages
pourront supporter le coût énergétique
il sera déterminant sur la compétitivité
de nos entreprises la relocalisation des
productions industrielles dans notre
pays quelque part au niveau de la
commission économique nous disons
souvent il y a dans un pays la
souveraineté alimentaire mais à
souveraineté énergétique et quasiment au
même niveau
ma première interrogation concerne sur
un Mons vous êtes diplômé de l'École
polytechnique vous avez été conseillé
ministériel au début des années 2000
vous avez travaillé à la Direction
générale de l'armement et à celle du
Trésor vous avez exercé dans le secteur
bancaire puis intégrer Schneider
Electric en 2014 dont vous êtes
actuellement le directeur général des
opérations internationales ce solide
parcours est toutefois un peu éloigné
des missions
de production et de fournitures
d'énergie telles que celle du groupe EDF
en quoi votre parcours peut-il vous
aider
dans vos fonctions de plus son lit dans
la presse que vous auriez conseillé la
vente de la branche énergie rastom à
General Electric lorsque vous étiez dans
le secteur bancaire est-ce le cas et
quel enseignement en tirez-vous
comment
ma deuxième est question interrogation
concerne le groupe EDF ces dernières
années ont été successivement annoncés
par le gouvernement le projet Hercule
devenu grand EDF puis la nationalisation
du groupe quel est votre point de vue
sur l'organisation de groupe une réforme
est-elle toujours à l'agenda avec une
scission des activités nucléaires et
renouvelables pensez-vous que la
Commission européenne puisse accepter en
l'absence de réformes une nouvelle
régulation du nucléaire existant et le
règlement du contentieux hydroélectrique
votre prédécesseur avait appelé à la
révision de la reine qualifiée par lui
de poison
et elle a mise à l'abri des concessions
via un mécanisme de quasi régie
êtes-vous sur la même ligne et la
nationalisation vous semble-t-elle
suffisante pour répondre au défi
financier économique et sociaux du
groupe
troisième interrogation sur Mons un
trait à la relance du nucléaire notre
commission a fait adopter à la quasi
unanimité en juillet un rapport très
complet intitulé nucléaire hydrogène
l'urgence d'agir tout est dit dans le
dite le titre dans ce rapport nous
appelons à redresser rapidement la
production du parc existant pouvez-vous
nous rassurer sur le phénomène de
corrosion sous contrainte qu'elle est
déjà votre analyse sur ce sujet
Quels sont vos prévisions de production
et de calendriers dans ce domaine sur la
remise en route avez-vous mis en oeuvre
le procédé ou pensez-vous que le procédé
de contrôle par
ultrason plus rapide des réacteurs sera
généralisé et permettra d'aller encore
bien plus vite quel est l'impact
financier sur le programme du grand
carénage et qu'en est-il de la mise en
service de la centrale de Flamanville
que nous avons eu le plaisir de visiter
au niveau de la commission d'affaires
économique le dernier de plus dans ce
rapport nous plaidons pour un mix
énergétique majoritairement nucléaire
d'ici 2050 afin de réaliser concrètement
le scénario n03 de RTE pour ce faire
nous souhaitons la commande ferme non
pas de 6 mais de 14 EPR et de 4 GW de
SMS nous solvons aussi quelques impensés
de la relance
annoncées du nucléaire pour RTE il
manque trois oppères en l'absence de
prolongation de la de 60 ans puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons toujours pas la
réponse et 9 EPR dans l'hypothèse d'une
réindustriation profonde que nous
souhaitons tous quel scénario et quel
nombre de réacteurs ont votre préférence
de plus il faut convenir d'un modèle de
financement à l'échelon européen se
financement passe par un consortium
d'électro-intensifs près de l'opérateur
ou de l'État ou encore des fonds propres
en contrepartie d'un prix de long terme
fixe ou révisable s'agissant la France
la Cour des comptes a indiqué que le
groupe ne pourrait assumer tout seul ce
financement quel est votre appréciation
des choses enfin une relance du
nucléaire nécessite des compétences la
construction des six EPR c'est déjà 30
000 emplois certes le groupe et la
filière ont réalisé un effort
considérable sur ce plan mais est-ce la
hauteur du défi l'État ne devrait-il pas
s'engager davantage de leur côté pour
atteindre des objectifs
ma quatrième interrogation a trait aux
énergies renouvelables et aux vecteurs
hydrogène le groupe EDF est très engagé
en faveur du déploiement de l'énergie
solaire de l'éolien en mer de
l'hydrogène du stockage ou de l'électro
mobilité les objectifs de 30 GW du Plan
solaire de 2017 de 10 gigawatts du plan
stockage de 2018 et de 3 gigawatts du
plan hydrogène de 2022 sont-ils encore
d'actualité 9 autorité une fois les
rehausser au regard de l'ambition du
paquet ajustement 55 et pourquoi ne pas
fixer d'objectifs en matière d'éolien en
mer dans notre rapport avec mes
collègues Jean-Pierre Moga et
Jean-Jacques Michaud nous avons plaidé
pour développer l’hydrogène aux côtés du
nucléaire car la stratégie française en
la matière doit avant tout se fonder sur
un hydrogène issu du réseau
d'électricité partagez-vous cette
position pensez-vous que le projet de
loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables soit suffisante au regard
des besoins de la transition énergétique
car il est complètement muet sur
l'hydroélectricité et d'hydrogène et ma
dernière question c'est vraiment
concerne le marché européen
l'électricité
étant donné que la crise énergétique
actuelle est aussi une crise européenne
d'une part les objectifs fixés par le
paquet ajustement à l'objectif 55 vous
semble-t-il réaliste dans ce cadre de
nos travaux avec ma collègue
dominicestrosi ça sonne nous avons
relevé un manque de neutralité tel
technologique en énergie renouvelable et
bas carbone et entre hydrogène
renouvelable et bas carbone cela nous
semble mettre en cause le droit
souverain des états définir leur mix
énergétique par TGV vous cette opinion
d'autre part les mesures proposées par
le plan
vous paraissent-elles suffisante la
révision du marché européen des CC avec
un découplage du prix d'excité celui du
gaz et souvent évoqué comment
l'imaginez-vous voilà Monsieur Raymond
on est question que je souhaitais vous
poser et je suis impatient d'entendre
vos réponses
[Rires]
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur rapporteur je vais essayer de
répondre aux questions monsieur
Grémillet dans mon propos liminaire pas
forcément toutes mais on pourra y
revenir juste après si vous le voulez
bien d'abord je voudrais dire madame le
Président de monsieur madame messieurs
les sénateurs que que c'est vraiment un
honneur pour moi de me présenter à vous
aujourd'hui
devant votre commission à la demande du
Président de la République qui vous a
saisi du projet de me nommer comme
président directeur général d'EDF si le
conseil d'administration d'EDF le
propose et si le Parlement la prouve
bien sûr vous n'entendez pas pardon
alors je vais me rapprocher du micro
voilà
alors par l'importance de sa mission et
grâce au succès qui ont émaillé son
histoire naturellement vous m'entendez
maintenant c'est bon
EDF est une fierté nationale dont nos
concitoyens attendent légitimement
beaucoup et les générations de femmes et
d'hommes qui ont façonné cette
entreprise depuis 1946 peuvent être
fiers de leur contribution au
développement de notre pays et c'est
convaincu du rôle essentiel et
stratégique que joue EDF et qu'il aura à
jouer dans les prochaines décennies et
de l'ampleur de la responsabilité de
diriger cette entreprise que je me
présente à vous aujourd'hui comme votre
commission va devoir se prononcer sur ma
capacité à assurer les fonctions de
président directeur général de DF il me
semble que je dois surmonter ma
réticence naturelle à parler de moi pour
vous dire d'abord deux choses l'une
générale l'autre plus personnelle avant
de vous décrire brièvement mon parcours
et d'essayer de répondre en cela à une
question du rapporteur la première chose
générale c'est je vois ce rôle moins
comme une fonction que comme une mission
l'énergie la transition énergétique
l'électricité son prix aujourd'hui
notamment le nucléaire les énergies
renouvelables les réseaux et englobat
tout cela tout cela l'avenir de DS
c'est évidemment un sujet qui dans les
temps que nous traversons suppose la
mobilisation de toutes les énergies à
commencer par la même
et donc je voudrais simplement vous dire
que j'y suis prêt et quand ça j'ai le
sentiment d'être d'ailleurs
totalement aligné et je suis convaincu
que tous les personnels de l'entreprise
sont également dans cet état d'esprit de
fortes mobilisation le second point qui
est plus personnel et le suivant si je
suis prêt à assumer cette mission que
vous avez qualifié de difficile madame
la Présidente c'est parce que j'y trouve
l'occasion de porter à leur
aboutissement des idéaux que je porte
depuis ma jeunesse
je crois avoir servi l'intérêt général
dans tous les postes que j'ai occupés
qui soient dans le secteur public ou
dans le secteur privé
mais EDF pour dire un peu familièrement
c'est autre chose parce que c'est
peut-être la mission d'une vie c'est
pour un homme qui au moment de ses
études à rêver d'être ingénieur au
moment des concours républicains a fait
de son mieux pour aller dans cette
direction
dans le but de servir l'industrie
française et pour qui vient le moment de
rendre par cette mission à son pays tout
ce qu'il a pu donner à un jeune français
comme les autres et je vais dans les
valeurs du mérite et du travail
alors pour vous dire un peu plus sur mon
parcours monsieur rapporteur je suis
ingénieur de formation je n'ai cessé
d'apprendre pendant bientôt 30 ans de
vie professionnelle qui ont été dédiées
pour moitié au service de l'État pour
moitié à la vie d'entreprise dans les
différents métiers qui m'ont offert la
chance d'une expérience diversifiée mon
parcours a toujours été focalisé sur le
développement de l'industrie française
et avec une très large partie dédié au
monde de l'énergie dans mes années au
service de l'État j'ai appris le
développement d'une filière
technologique complexe dans les systèmes
spatiaux à la Direction générale de
l'armement puis au trésor celui des
grands projets d'infrastructure avec les
banques de développement
j'ai participé au négociations du
protocole de Kyoto sur le changement
climatique j'ai suivi la mise en sûreté
des centrales nucléaires du bloc de
l'Est à la fin des années 90 je j'ai
ensuite au début des années 2000 de
Somme toujours au sein du ministère des
Finances j'ai soutenu le développement
la transformation des entreprises
est actionnaires dans une période
d'évolution rapide notamment de toutes
les entreprises du secteur public à la
fois pour leur régulation et pour leurs
projets industriels j'ai connu
naturellement de nombreuses négociations
communautaires à cette période et c'est
aussi à cette période que j'ai découvert
le secteur de l'énergie qui vivait l'une
de ses premières mutations à l'échelle
européenne il y en a bien sûr eu
beaucoup d'autres depuis
j'ai souhaité ensuite apprendre
davantage en exerçant une activité
opérationnelle dans le monde de
l'entreprise j'ai commencé dans le
secteur financier au moment de la crise
financière j'ai appris la conduite d'une
activité en crise alors que le monde
financier s'écroulait l'importance de
rester proche de ses clients en toute
circonstances
et j'ai continué de développer ma
connaissance de l'industrie française et
internationale en accompagnant le
développement stratégique et le
financement de nombreux groupes je
reviendrai plus tard si vous le
permettez sur le groupe Alstom monsieur
le rapporteur enfin depuis bientôt 9 ans
c'est avec beaucoup de bonheur que je
sers le groupe Schneider Electric un
autre fleuron notre industrie française
qui est à leader technologique mondial
engagé dans la décarbonation de la
planète grâce à l'électrification de nos
usages et à l'utilisation de technologie
digitale pour améliorer l'efficacité
énergétique et opérationnelle de tout
type d'infrastructures je dirige depuis
bientôt 6 ans l'activité du groupe dans
une soixantaine de pays principalement
les pays émergents qui représente
environ un quart de chiffre d'affaires
du groupe avec une présence
opérationnelle industrielle et humaine
très forte mon activité m'amène à
diriger des équipes pluridisciplinaires
de culture extrêmement différente
et de développer leur compétences au
service de nos clients de notre
technologie et de notre capacité
industrielle ma conduit à travailler
avec la plupart des opérateurs
électriques de ces pays pour leur
modernisation technique et numérique et
à connaître l'évolution de marché de
l'électricité extrêmement variés
enfin pendant cette période à la demande
de l'État j'ai été pendant 5 ans membre
du conseil d'administration de naval
group me donnant l'occasion de suivre de
près comme président du comité d'audit
de ce groupe le seul programme de série
de chaufferies nucléaires à ce jour en
France qui est le programme des
sous-marins d'attaque Barracuda
c'est nourri de ces expériences
diversifiées et conscient qu'il me faut
encore beaucoup apprendre que j'aborde
cette nouvelle phase de ma vie
professionnelle au-delà des compétences
et de l'expérience accumulée je sais que
la réussite de la mission suppose
d'abord de mobiliser toute l'entreprise
et l'ensemble des parties prenantes
autour d'un projet d'avenir pour
l'électricité dans lequel le DEF jouera
pleinement son rôle j'y trouve une très
grande motivation et je voudrais
partager avec vous quelques idées
initiales qui ne sont que celles d'un
observateur extérieur à l'entreprise
pour l'instant et sur la façon dont je
perçois les priorités stratégiques pour
EDF
tout d'abord vous l'avez rappelé madame
la Présidente et monsieur le rapporteur
nous sommes dans un contexte critique à
court terme qui rappelle le rôle
essentiel joué par l'énergie et en
particulier par les triciers dans nos
sociétés alors que l'Europe a bénéficié
d'une grande sécurité énergétique
pendant plusieurs décennies l'énergie
devenue aujourd'hui une arme dont
use la Russie pour affaiblir nos
sociétés et diviser l'Union européenne
donc avant même de parler de prix de
l'énergie c'est notre capacité à
disposer de suffisamment d'énergie pour
répondre à nos besoins qui est un enjeu
avec l'arrêt d'approvisionnement de
l'Europe en gaz russe notamment
malheureusement dans ce contexte de
crise énergétique EDF traverse elle-même
une crise sérieuse d'ordre technique et
industriel qui accentue l'attention sur
l'offre d'énergie
alors vous avez parlé du phénomène qui
est inattendu de corrosion sur sous
contrainte sur certains qui ont
nucléaires qui est venu soudainement
aggraver la tendance baissière qu'on
observait de plus un certain nombre
d'années de la production nucléaire
li au vieillissement du parc et à la
nécessité d'entretien je n'ai pas à ce
stade une connaissance suffisante de ce
phénomène pour livrer un diagnostic mais
ce que je constate c'est que
l'entreprise en liaison avec l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire à appliquer d'emblée
des mesures de de sûreté et en mettant
la sûreté au premier plan ce qui
constitue un essentiel un élément
essentiel du pacte de confiance qui unit
EDF à la nation et que immédiatement
l'entreprise en liaison avec les
entreprises de la filière et l'Autorité
de sûreté ont mis en oeuvre un plan qui
permet de développer les solutions
adaptées dans la meilleure délais pour
permettre la reprise de production en
toute sûreté
j'étais confronté moi-même plusieurs
fois à des difficultés de production
soit au sein de Schneider Electric soit
chez nos clients chez les Electric est
un opérateur qui fournit des solutions
de de procéder industriels et de
sécurité dans les procédés industriels
donc ça nous arrive aussi je sais que ça
nécessite le la mobilisation de toute
l'entreprise et de l'ensemble du secteur
je pense qu'aujourd'hui cette
mobilisation est celle de DF et dès les
premières heures de mon mandat si vous
me confirmez dans cette direction je me
consacrerai totalement à la tête et aux
côtés des équipes d'EDF avec les
entreprises de la filière à tenir les
engagements d'entreprise pour la reprise
de la production des réacteurs à l'arrêt
alors au-delà de la production
électrique nucléaire la situation de
tension énergétique liée au gaz et elle
est hydroélectricité qu'il faut pas
oublier parce que la sécheresse de l'été
dans toute l'Europe
à des effets sur la production
électrique
pour pour cet hiver dans toute l'Europe
nous impose de nous préparer
collectivement au passage de l'hiver par
un effort de réduction de notre
consommation je suis convaincu de très
longues dates de la nécessité de la
sobriété et de l'efficacité énergétique
je soutiens totalement les initiatives
permettant à chacun d'agir en citoyens
et cet effort collectif est
indispensable pour alléger la demande et
diminuer les risques de délestage cet
hiver et les suivants et donc nous
continuerons
en ce sens le prix de l'électricité bien
sûr la résultante de toutes ces tensions
et sur le gaz le nucléaire mais aussi
l'hydrogique à l'hydraulique à l'échelle
européenne à court terme les clients
français bénéficient d'une meilleure
protection que les voisins européens
le prix de l'Est saisie en Europe est en
moyenne deux fois plus élevé qu'en
France aujourd'hui il existe pourtant
des situations difficiles et certains
d'entre vous ont déjà parlé et je j'en
suis bien conscient je le sais je n'en
suis pas satisfait je travaillerai avec
les clients de DF et avec le
gouvernement pour trouver les solutions
adaptées chaque fois que c'est possible
dans ce contexte la situation financière
de DF ce temps sous l'effet conjugué de
la baisse de la production et des
mesures de régulation destinées à
limiter les hausse de prix de
l'électricité ces situations nécessitent
de la vigilance à court terme pour ne
pas devoir réduire les investissements
et compromettre l'avenir elle devrait
s'améliorer avec la reprise de la
production du parc nucléaire mais elle
nécessite impérativement de trouver un
équilibre une visibilité de long terme
de la régulation permettant de nous
engager dans un nouveau cycle
d'investissement devenu indispensable
ceci me conduit maintenant à aborder les
perspectives de moyen terme d'EDF en
essayant de répondre à certaines des
autres questions de monsieur le
rapporteur
tous les experts internationaux
confirment le rôle grandissant de
l'électricité de décarbonée
dont toutes les formes devront être
mobilisées le nucléaire l'hydraulique
l'éolien le soleil le thermique des
carbonés le stockage la flexibilité les
Smart Grids j'ai vu dans mes fonctions
actuelles à quel point ce mouvement est
mondial
et à quel point la croissance des
besoins en électricité nécessite une
intelligence de système de la production
aux clients en passant par les réseaux
je suis convaincu que nous sommes au
début d'une révolution industrielle
fondée sur l'électricité et le numérique
et de l'importance de l'électricité pour
atteindre l'ambition de la France d'être
neutre en carbone en 2050
de manière générale EDF est attendu
comme un acteur absolument majeur dans
cette transition au fil des dernières
années évidemment EDF a connu une mue
très importante du grand service public
de l'électricité engagée dans la
production électrique dans les réseaux
la commercialisation d'un tarif unique
il s'est transformé en l'espace de deux
décennies en un acteur d'un marché
européen concurrentiel producteur
d'électricité aussi bien nucléaire que
renouvelable développant et construisant
des installations de production
d'électricité des carbonée en France et
en Europe et dans le monde
son offre commerciale s'est
considérablement diversifiée pour
satisfaire les attentes du marché et les
réseaux se sont adaptés à la
décentralisation et à la numérisation
c'est aujourd'hui un grand énergéticien
mondial et qui doit continuer à tenir ce
rang
grâce à l'étendue et à la qualité des
compétences dont elle dispose et par la
nature même de sa raison d'être EDF est
bien placé pour jouer ce rôle de premier
plan dans ce nouveau monde électrique et
je voudrais détailler un certain de
piliers stratégiques qui me paraissait
essentiel pour la succès le succès de la
mission de DF j'ai observé beaucoup
d'opérateurs électriques dans le monde
et je crois que le succès de leur
mission repose sur la capacité de
développer de façon optimale 3 piliers
d'activités qui constituent un système
d'ensemble
comme pour toute industrie les solutions
permettant aux clients d'optimiser leur
consommation énergétique d'une part une
production compétitive et résiliente de
diverses sources d'électricité d'autre
part et enfin des réseaux permettant
d'assurer la fourniture et l'équilibre
partout et à tout moment dans le respect
bien sûr de leur gouvernance spécifique
je commencerai par les clients sans
qu'il y ait aucune entreprise n'existe
encore plus pour EDF dont le rôle est
premier dans la satisfaction des besoins
collectifs les difficultés de court
terme sur les prix de l'électricité
doivent conduire à accélérer les
solutions permettant aux clients
entreprises particuliers collectivités
de mieux gérer leur énergie il y a
d'ores et déjà une accélération massive
en France des raccordements
d'auto-consommation qui est un
rattrapage par rapport à d'autres pays
EDF doit continuer à accompagner ses
clients dans leur transition énergétique
cela concerne les entreprises et les
collectivités dans leurs installations
industrielles ou tertiaires ou pour
développer des outils intelligents pour
les aider à piloter leur consommation
cela concerne également les particuliers
qui souhaitent réduire leur consommation
électrifier leur véhicule installer une
pompe à chaleur ou devenir
autoconsommateur ces évolutions un cycle
développement de la capacité de stockage
permettront d'introduire davantage de
flexibilité dans le système électrique
et qui en a grandement besoin et
d'accompagner l'électrification des
usages en limitant les volumes d'in
moyen de production centralisée la
priorité d'EDF est donc d'apporter
toutes ces solutions innovantes à
l'ensemble de ses clients
je voudrais maintenant aborder les
enjeux de la production électrique nous
sommes à la croisée des chemins comme
les analyses de très grande qualité
publiées par RTE sur les différents
scénarios de production et
d'investissement d'ici 2050
l'ont montré avec une perspective très
éclairante sur l'avenir
sans entrer dans le détail de du
commentaire de chaque scénario de ce qui
a beaucoup de scénarios qui montrent un
éventail de situations possibles
il me paraît raisonnable dire que le
problème qui se pose à nous aujourd'hui
et moins de piloter finement la part de
chaque mode de production que de nous
mettre en mesure collectivement de
produire suffisamment de chacun de ces
modes pour assurer une production une
production suffisante et diversifiée à
terme
donc je vais passer en revue ces
différents modes en commençant par le
nucléaire et simplement partager avec
vous ma vision de la façon dont on peut
évoluer sur chacun de ces modes alors il
est clair qu'il y a pas de stratégie bas
carbone possible sans production
nucléaire
c'est évidemment une approche de la
France depuis très longtemps ce qui est
intéressant c'est que de plus en plus de
pays parviennent à cette conclusion et
je l'ai constaté dans mes fonctions
d'aujourd'hui
tout simplement parce que le nucléaire
est la seule énergie
source de production électrique
aujourd'hui fournissant une électricité
de base non carbonée nous avons la
chance que nos anciens et réussit une
performance inouïe qui est le développer
une filière industrielle et de déployer
58 réacteurs en moins de 20 ans
qui nous permet de bénéficier
aujourd'hui d'une électricité
compétitive et abondante
entretenir et prolonger la durée vie de
ce parc et naturellement la première
priorité d'investissement de DF avec le
programme du grand carénage mais il nous
faut également être prêt pour le moment
où la performance de nos anciens nous
rattrapera sous forme d'un effet falaise
lorsqu'on ne pourra plus
prolonger ce parc et où il nous faudra
trouver une source de renouvellement
c'est la raison pour laquelle le nouveau
programme nucléaire français doit
maintenant être rapidement lancée pour
que nous disposions durablement d'une
électricité de base suffisante et c'est
le cas fixé par le président de la
République dans son discours de Belfort
alors c'est d'abord un défi humain
c'est bien comme ça que je le prends je
suis convaincu de disposer des
compétences les plus pointues dans
l'ensemble de la filière nucléaire et
cruciale pour parvenir à relever le
niveau de production et pour sécuriser
aussi le grand programme industriel qui
s'annonce avec la construction des
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires j'ai
conscience du rôle singulier de DF à la
tête de la filière nucléaire qu'elle
recompose activement avec l'intégration
de Framatome en 2018 bientôt sans doute
avec celle des activités nucléaires de
General Electric il nous faudra
structurer amplifier le travail mener
depuis quelques années pour attirer les
talents dans ces métiers
attirer à nouveau à nouveau vers
l'industrie en France et j'aurais à cœur
de garantir que la filière dispose
durablement des compétences nécessaires
pour relever le grand défi qui se
présente à elle naturellement il y a de
nombreuses autres dimensions nous
pourrons y revenir technique financières
industrielle à ce défi ce n'est pas
seulement celui de l'entreprise mais
celui de la nation et je m'attacherai à
définir avec les pouvoirs publics
l'ensemble des modalité nécessaire au
succès ce programme avec l'obsession de
fournir aux Français une électricité
abondante sur compétitive et durable
dans les meilleurs délais
je voudrais passer maintenant à
l'hydraulique et au renouvelable si vous
le voulez bien nous devons aussi trouver
un chemin de développement pour
l'hydraulique l'eau est une ressource
dans les usages sont multiples
absolument majeurs que ce soit pour
l'énergie l'agriculture le tourisme et
nous devons exploiter tout son potentiel
le rôle de DF auprès des collectivités
et d'assurer la cohérence de la
ressource tout au long des cours d'eau
et de conjuguer une production
hydrolelectrique durable et les autres
usages tout en préservant la
biodiversité
les projets d'investissement ne se
réalisent pas aujourd'hui par manque de
visibilité sur le cadre de long terme
donc je sais que les discussions sont en
cours monsieur le rapporteur vous les
avez mentionnés sur
sur comment fournir un tel cadre AEDF et
je m'attacherai à ce qu'elles
aboutissent pour permettre de relancer
ce secteur le développement des
renouvelables je sais qu'il vous occupe
beaucoup y compris la nuit en ce moment
est également une composante essentielle
d'une production diversifiée pour EDF en
tant qu'opérateur de système électrique
EDF s'il y avait largement engagé avec
des partenaires financiers permettant de
partager les besoins d'investissement
la France n'est pas en reste dans le
développement d'EDF dans les unr puisque
le groupe est leader de l'éolien
terrestre il est leader l'éolien
maritime en France et dans le podium sur
le solaire mais nous savons qu'il faut
accélérer EDF ne sera naturellement
performant en France que en restant un
acteur mondial dont la taille critique
permet de bénéficier d'effet d'échelle
d'avoir des conditions d'achat optimales
en partageant naturellement avec des
partenaires les investissements
nécessaires pour ne pas peser
excessivement sur la capacité de
financement du groupe
le troisième pilier indispensable du
système électrique et la performance des
réseaux les réseaux de transport et
distribution sont eux-mêmes en pleine
mutation pour faciliter la transition
énergétique et l'importance de
l'électricité dans notre quotidien amène
logiquement à une très grande exigence
de qualité
le métier de la distribution électrique
est très fortement ancrée dans le
territoire et accompagne les changements
profonds associés à la production
renouvelable décentralisée
la flexibilité accrue de l'offre et la
demande d'électricité locale change
profondément la nature du métier de
gestionnaire de réseau et nécessite des
investissements importants en raccordant
et en raccordement et en système
numérique et ça je l'ai vu dans le monde
entier nous passons d'un système
unidirectionnel qui permettait
l'acheminement de l'électricité depuis
de grands centres de production vers les
consommateurs un système bidirectionnel
qui mal au territoire en permettant la
flexibilité et l'échange d'électricité
c'est une c'est une évolution c'est même
une révolution qui se passe dans tous
les pays du monde et la priorité pour
EDF dans le respect de la gouvernance
spécifique des réseaux bien sûr et de
soutenir ces transformations dans un
cadre de régulation adapté
je voudrais ajouter un point simple mais
essentiel répondant cela en partie je
pense à monsieur le rapporteur aussi qui
est que pour répondre à tous ces enjeux
stratégiques du système électrique ce ne
sera possible que si nous réformons
profondément les règles de marché
à l'échelle européenne bien sûr et en
partie à l'échelle nationale pour
permettre l'investissement et donner à
EDF un cadre de moyen terme stable
la crise énergétique actuelle vous
l'avez souligné les madame la prisante
mais en lumière un certain nombre de
faiblesses de nos règles de marché
européens
les gouvernements européens adapté des
mesures d'urgence pour faire face au
défi les plus immédiats et protéger les
consommateurs des hausses exorbitantes
de prix de gros en agissant sur le gaz
électrogène et sur les prix de
production d'électricité mais au-delà de
la crise actuelle il est indispensable
de réfléchir au futur cadre de marché
européen pour compenser les défaillances
des règles de marché mise en lumière par
la crise actuelle
le premier je vous livre quelques idées
qui sont des idées préliminaires et sur
lesquels il faudra naturellement que je
travaille beaucoup et pas tout seul avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur le
premier élément c'est que nous avons un
cadre de marché qui est trop
exclusivement focalisé sur le court
terme et sur l'équilibre de court terme
la deuxième défaillance est que il y a
naturellement une conséquence lourde de
la formation du prix de l'électricité à
partir du prix du gaz alors que
l'évolution du mix de production fait
que le prix du gaz représente une cote
part de gaz représente une cote-part de
plus en plus faible de la production
électricité que nous avons de plus en
plus de production à coût variable nulle
le troisième élément c'est qu'il y a une
insuffisante prise en compte des besoins
de flexibilité dans le fonctionnement du
marché notamment sous forme de contrat
de long terme et de pilotage de la
demande voilà les éléments qui pour
quelqu'un qui a opéré dans beaucoup
d'autres marchés électriques revient
vers le marché européen frappe et donc
sur lesquels je compte travailler
je suis heureux de voir que le sommet
européen de la semaine dernière a permis
d'engager le travail communautaire pour
repenser le cadre de marché et
évidemment EDF apportera ses idées et
son expertise aux autorités françaises
et européenne à qui il revient de fixer
le cadre de marché
dans le cas plus spécifique de DF le
mécanisme de l'arène est à bout de
souffle
si il a permis de protéger les clients
de prix de marché trop élevés y compris
en ce moment il n'a pas permis de
développer de véritables investissements
concurrents tout en affaiblissement tout
en affaiblissant sérieusement ceux d'EDF
donc son échéance est fixé à 2025 et je
m'attacherai à créer avec l'État et la
Commission européenne l'indispensable
visibilité à moyen terme nécessaire pour
sécuriser la trajectoire
d'investissement d'EDF pour le pays je
terminerai ce volet stratégiques d'un
mot sur la préparation de l'avenir parce
que je pourrais beaucoup plus long et je
le serai trop
comme ingénieur je suis convaincu que
l'évolution technologique va continuer
de nous apporter des solutions nouvelles
pour l'électricité c'est le rôle d'EDF
dans le domaine de la R&D recherche et
développement d'y contribuer et c'est
aussi la raison de la présence à
l'internationale qui est destinée à
connaître et à pratiquer des
environnements électriques différents
surtout ces aspects stratégiques qui
s'inscrivent dans la conduite continuité
de la raison d'être def définie sous
l'égide de Jean-Bernard Lévy avec une
très large participation de l'ensemble
de l'entreprise
j'engagerai un travail en profondeur
avec les équipes de DF dans les premiers
mois destinés à proposer une feuille de
route d'ici le printemps
au moment de conclure je voudrais
partager avec vous quelques convictions
fortes qui guident mon action en tant
que dirigeant d'entreprise je crois que
la satisfaction des clients est le
premier objectif de toute entreprise je
crois que la réussite de l'entreprise
n'est possible que par l'engagement et
le développement des compétences et des
talents des personnes qui la composent
que la diversité des origines et des
savoirs et la mixité sont indispensables
à la réussite d'une équipe que le
dialogue entre les parties prenantes de
l'entreprise et le dialogue social crée
la confiance nécessaire au progrès que
la concurrence et la compétition sont
bénéfiques à l'entreprise en la poussant
à faire mieux sans cesse
que la culture de l'engagement et de la
performance est indispensable en la
poussant à la réussite d'un projet
d'entreprise que la responsabilité
sociale d'entreprise est un engagement
et pas une contrainte et qu'il est
possible de concilier la préservation de
la planète le développement et le
bien-être et que l'électricité
décarbonée est un atout majeur de
progrès et d'industrialisation alors EDF
n'est certes pas une entreprise comme
les autres des posters du modèle du
service public et animé par l'intérêt
général
l'entreprise doit relever en même temps
nombreux défis au-delà des défis du
moment je crois qu'elle est en mesure de
renouer avec l'excellence et
l'exemplarité industrielle qui fait
notre fierté partout dans le monde et de
jouer un rôle majeur dans l'avenir
électrique
l'actionnariat de DF est appelé à
évoluer dans le cadre du projet de
l'état de détenir 100% du capital en
tant qu'actionnaire de long terme en
pleine accord avec l'état actionnaires
je veux dire ici que les EDF restera
gérés comme une entreprise industrielle
avec son intérêt social et sa
personnalité morale propre et ce sera
naturellement ma mission et ma façon de
travailler
je souhaite aborder cette mission en
bâtissant une vision d'avenir une
relation confiante avec les pouvoirs
publics indispensable pour réussir à
relever les défis d'ampleur national qui
sont devant nous le DF ne peut réussir à
servir le pays qu'avec cette relation de
confiance je m'attacherai à ce qu'elle
soit nourrie de contacts réguliers avec
votre commission et avec l'ensemble des
élus dans les territoires et je serai
naturellement heureux de revenir devant
vous
si naturellement vous confirmez ma
nomination dans quelques mois si vous le
permettez voilà madame la Présidente
Monsieur rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
de votre attention je suis naturellement
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions en vous remerciant de bien
vouloir m'excuser si mes réponses à ce
stade sont celles d'un observateur
extérieur peuvent manquer un peu de
précision et peut-être si vous me le
permettez madame présente puis-je
commencer par essayer de répondre à
celle des questions de monsieur le
rapporteur que je n'aurais pas d'ores et
déjà couverts dans dans mon propos
liminaire
Alstom alors Alstom donc comme dans tout
sujet industriels il faut un peu de
perspective parce que les faits
industriels sont sur le long terme
je rappelle qu'elle stom à
qui au tout début des années 2000
l'activité de production électrique de
turbine à gaz notamment d'un groupe
suédo Suisse qui s'appelle ABB
et que c'est acquisition a amené Alstom
tout au bord de la faillite à l'été 2003
puisque les turbines en question
n'étaient pas de qualité et donc avait
conduit l'ensemble des clients de cette
urbine a réclamé Alstom 4 milliards
d'euros
à l'époque le ministre des Finances que
j'avais l'honneur de servir et qui je
veux rendre hommage ici qui était
Francis Mer après une décision
courageuse qui est de dire nous
laisserons pas Alstom partir à la
faillite et nous nous mettrons en place
un plan qui permet de pérenniser
l'ensemble des activités d'Alsace
et Alstom continuer son chemin
traversant cette crise très difficile
et se redressant et donc cette activité
de production électrique de turbine qui
était des turbines à gaz à vapeur etc
etc a poursuivi son chemin sur une
décennie traversant d'autres défis donc
les défis qui ont suivi ont été
naturellement la crise financière et
puis l'accélération de la transition
énergétique dans le monde entier si bien
que au début de la décennie 2010
le monde des turbines à gaz notamment le
monde est fabricants de turbines à gaz
étaient en crise mondiale parce que plus
aucune nouvelle turbine à gaz n'était
fabriquée ou que ce soit et ce métier ne
vivait plus que de la maintenance de la
base installée des turbines à gaz et
Alstom qui était convalescent dans ce
monde là les leaders mondiaux étant
General Electric Siemens et Mitsubishi
s'est retrouvé dans la situation dans
laquelle ce métier allait souffrait
énormément et risquer à nouveau
d'emmener l'ensemble du groupe dans des
difficultés et donc les dirigeants
d'Alstom de l'époque ont naturellement
cherché les évolutions stratégiques
indispensables pour préserver cette
activité d'une part mais également
préserver la compétitivité de l'ensemble
du groupe et c'est dans ce cadre que
en tant que banquier d'affaires je m'en
excuse c'est un métier j'ai été j'ai été
amené à participer simplement à la prise
de contact initial avec General Electric
qui est un grand industriel
partenaire de safran depuis 50 ans ayant
permis à safran de devenir avec général
Alexis grands ensemble leader mondial
d'un des segments du plus large segment
des moteurs aéronautiques donc c'est
aussi un grand partenaire de
d'industriels français donc voilà j'ai
participé à ce premier contact et
ensuite j'étais parti chez Schneider
Electric donc je n'ai pas suivi le reste
de cette de cette transformation
très bien merci beaucoup je vais activer
le processus de questions vous êtes
extrêmement nombreux ce qui montre
l'intérêt que notre commission porte
évidemment à EDF et à votre nomination
je demanderai donc à nos collègues de
poser vite leurs questions vraiment une
minute 30 maximum parce que nous devons
laisser Monsieur Raymond à 10h30 vous
êtes aujourd'hui 15 à poser des
questions pour aller à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pas une fantaisie de sa
part c'est juste une obligation voilà on
va commencer par Jean-Claude Tissot
ensuite Jean-Pierre Moga merci madame la
Présidente je vais être très bref
Monsieur Raymond bonjour
j'ai une seule question pour que nous
ayons une vision précise de votre
orientation et de vos objectifs pour EDF
après avoir suivi la privatisation des
autoroutes et de la Société Nationale
maritime Corse Méditerranée après avoir
participé à la libéralisation du marché
de l'énergie et de la privatisation de
GDF après avoir travaillé pour
l'introduction en Bourse d'EDF
lors de vos passages dans les cabinets
ministériels de Bercy après avoir
supervisé la vente d'Alstom à générer
électrique lors de votre passage dans
une banque d'investissement comment
l'expert de la privatisation et de la
libéralisation que vous êtes contagir
pour participer à la relation d'EDF
n'est-ce pas un aveu que le projet
Hercule est de retour avec une
privatisation à venir des actifs
intéressants et une simple
nationalisation de la production
nucléaire merci Monsieur Merci
Jean-Claude Jean-Pierre mauguet ensuite
Fabien gay si madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Raymond d'or c'est déjà
j'avais plusieurs questions mais vous
avez répondu à certaines dont je ne
voulais reposerai pas notamment il y en
avait une sur la reine je voulais vous
interroger moi sur les SMR ces petites
ces petits réacteurs modulaires qu'on
peut fabriquer en série exporter ou
utiliser sur le territoire national à
notre mère etc à des endroits où on n'a
pas de la possibilité aujourd'hui en
dehors des énergies fossiles de produire
de l'électricité donc je voulais savoir
la stratégie que vous envisagez de
porter au sein du groupe EDF pour
fabriquer développer et commercialiser
ce type de petites centrales Sacha que
vous avez fait allusion vous avez été
chez naval group on a quand même au
niveau national une expérience avec les
chaufferies des sous-marins et de et de
notre porte-avion voilà je vous remercie
merci pardon de vous de vous presser
Fabien gay ensuite Martine Berthet merci
et ces usagers deux questions moi j'ai
pas bien compris ce que vous pensiez sur
la reine il faut que moi qui a un
système de spoliation de DF et ses
usagers faut-il en finir avant 2025 et
quel régulation vous proposer après et
la deuxième chose moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est votre feuille de route on est
privé de débat parlementaire on a une
réétatisation d'EDF sans débat qui va
rester une société anonyme et donc c'est
quoi votre feuille de route est-ce que
c'est reprendre un Hercule 2.0 avec une
filialisation une vente d'actifs vous
allez avoir en tête une grande
entreprise avec 70 milliards de dettes
est-ce que vous allez vendre des actifs
comme Dalkia est-ce que c'est se séparer
d'un certain nombre d'activités ou de
salariés ou est-ce que vous venez pour
créer ou recréer un grand service public
de l'énergie je merci beaucoup Fabien
Martine Bertin ensuite Bernard but merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur Raymond
quelles actions comptez-vous pensez-vous
pouvoir entreprendre avec 100% du
capital par rapport aux 84 % précédent
quelles actions supplémentaires et alors
la question est un peu liée au niveau
des concessions des barrages comment que
pensez-vous qu'il va se passer merci
merci beaucoup Tina Bernard buis ensuite
Viviane Artigalas merci présidente deux
questions rapidement Monsieur Raymond
vous allez travailler sur l'introduction
en Bourse DDF en 2005 aujourd'hui EDF et
l'objet d'une Renault nationalisation
avec quel état d'esprit comptez-vous
aborder cette nouvelle étape dans la vie
d'EDF si votre candidature est retenue
la deuxième question porte sur la
relance de l'énergie nucléaire quels
seront vos priorités la relance du parc
nucléaire est aujourd'hui retardée en
raison d'une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée aurait DF s'est engagé à
redémarrer tous les secteur à l'arrêt
pour cet hiver comme la souligner la
ministre Agnès panière une Achille en
septembre dernier cette promesse
est-elle tenable qu'elle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour réussir
réussir ce défi et puis sénateur de moi
je vous glisse bien sûr que le
territoire de Pierre latte Bollen
Saint-Paul-Trois-Châteaux verrai d'un
bon œil la danse la construction du
troisième EPR prochainement tout est
prêt
Viviane est là oui merci donc les
questions étaient posées c'est sur les
concessions hydroélectriques que je mets
je vais compléter celle de Martine
Berthet en demandant vous aussi est-ce
que vous avez une feuille de route si
les questions restent là sur de nouveaux
développements sur des investissements à
faire est-ce que vous avez des objectifs
à ce sujet
tout Viviane Amel gaker qui est ici
madame la Présidente Monsieur Raymond
cela a été dit les enjeux du groupe EDF
sont nombreux et ceux dans un contexte
budgétaire plus que tendu pour EDF
notamment un enjeu d'indépendance
énergétique également une énergie
accessible à tous à un prix acceptable
vous avez déjà apporté pas mal de
réponses par contre deux sujets n'ont
pas encore été évoqués précisément
l'impact du coût de l'indépendance
énergétique sur les ménages français il
va falloir leur expliquer que
l'électricité va coûter de plus en plus
cher c'est un fait comment comptez-vous
engager cette évolution dans un contexte
de baisse généralisée du pouvoir d'achat
à plusieurs reprises ont été évoquées
également
les
investissements nécessaires pour
renouveler optimiser le parc nucléaire
notamment les six EPR de seconde
génération annoncées par le président
par contre n'a pas encore été évoqué le
sujet sensible des déchets à longue
durée de vie une question essentielle
pour les pays équipés de réacteurs
nucléaires qui arrivent en sincèrement
en fin de vie pour notre parc nucléaire
français
vieillissant et défectueux fonctionnant
à 50%. donc quel est votre vision sur ce
point sensible pour nous concitoyens
pour tous merci merci beaucoup Amel
Françoise Ferrat pardon excuse-moi
Françoise qui est là ensuite Laurent
Duplomb et je dis à mes collègues que je
vous prends dans l'ordre de la boucle
WhatsApp voilà donc
merci madame la Présidente une question
que je pense particulière Monsieur
Raymond si mes informations sont justes
une concertation organisée par le
gouvernement a été lancé pour permettre
au grand public de s'exprimer sur
l'avenir du bouquet énergétique français
avec évidemment le nucléaire au cœur des
débats trois grandes questions seront
posées avec comme objectif la neutralité
carbone en 2050 première question
comment adapter notre consommation
comment satisfaire nos besoins
énergétiques tout en sortant de notre
dépendance
les énergies fossiles et comment
planifier et financer notre transition
énergétique alors évidemment je suis
attaché à la concertation mais Monsieur
Raymond je m'interroge sur la méthode
qui pourrait vous permettre la prise en
compte du résultat des réponses du
public et avez-vous déjà élaboré cette
méthode
merci beaucoup Françoise Laurent Duplo
ensuite Franck Menonville merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur Raymond dans la
vie il y a des éléments extrinsèques et
des éléments intrinsèques dans les
éléments extra sec j'avais plutôt envie
de ne pas voter pour votre
accession à la présidence d'EDF mon avis
a plutôt évolué au vu de ce que vous
faites et du moins de ce que vous dites
puisque vous répondez directement aux
questions et vous n'êtes pas venu avec
une batterie de conseils qui vous
expliquerait ce qu'il faudrait que vous
disiez de façon à ne pas prendre de
risques ou quoi que ce soit et je trouve
que c'est un point positif qui va
réviser ma position
dans les éléments dans
dans les éléments dans les éléments
intrinsèques oui parce que tout
simplement je pense qu'à un moment donné
on crève de cette technocratie
abrutissante qui nous fait dire des
messages qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité qui nous font prendre autre
chose que les bonnes questions que tout
le monde donc s'il te plaît rapidement
dans les vraiment intrinsèque
dernièrement j'ai un exemple sur mon
département ou un jeune reprend une
scierie dépêche-toi 8000 euros de de
charges d'électricité avant de le
reprendre une fois qu'il l'a repris
refait son contrat avec EDF on lui
annonce 69000 €. la réponse qu'on lui
donne s'il va avoir un tarif
préférentiel c'est de signer de 9h du
soir à 5h du matin est-ce que là-dessus
vous allez pouvoir modifier ses réponses
qui sont complètement débiles et qui
consiste à ne pas répondre à ceux qui se
posent des questions et des questions
vitales sur l'avenir de leur entreprise
merci beaucoup
Franck menoville ensuite Florence
blatrix compta
Raymond une question rapide
vous avez évoqué le président de la
République a évoqué le renouvellement du
parc nucléaire l'ouverture d'un nouveau
programme vous le vous souhaitez bien
évidemment le le porter ma question elle
est très claire comment vous
imaginez-vous son déploiement sur le sur
le territoire et se fera t-il on
vérifier ou proche des installations
existantes allez vous réouvrir des
chantiers de concertation territoriale
pour la pour l'implantation de ces
notamment de ces epères et puis pour
renvoyer à deux questions de mes
collègues je suis avec Gérard Longuet
mais deux collègues de Haute-Marne
sénateurs de du département d'accueil du
projet cigeo donc j'aurais souhaité
aussi vous entendre sur le sujet et puis
la complémentarité territoriale le père
et SMR voilà
Franck Florence blastrix contact qui est
là-bas et ensuite Serge Mérillou merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur Raymond je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
stratégie de coopération internationale
et européenne d'EDF le savoir-faire de
DF vous l'avez dit et c'est différente
entités et largement reconnues ça me
conduit tout d'abord à vous interroger
sur le grand chantier
d'inclimpoint où en est-il c'est un
chantier stratégique pour la France et
le Royaume-Uni mais il pèsera lourdement
dans vos comptes par ailleurs c'est un
investissement réalisé avec le concours
de la compagnie chinoise c'est GN qui
est un partenaire de longue date d'EDF
notamment pour les réacteurs européens
conduits à taille Chan comment
envisagez-vous la poursuite de cette
coopération industrielle alors même que
cette entreprise est parfois concurrent
pour EDF et enfin peut-être une question
aussi sur le la relation
la coopération avec l'Allemagne le
couple franco-allemand a toujours été
important dans notre politique
énergétique pendant longtemps très lié
ces deux pays on semblait avoir des
politiques énergétiques divergentes
après le retrait de Siemens de du
nucléaire quand l'Allemagne a décidé de
se retirer quels sont aujourd'hui les
axes de coopération franco-allemande
dans votre secteur que ce soit pour
l'électricité le nucléaire le
renouvelable et quelles sont les
coopérations visage avec les industriels
allemands je vous remercie
[Musique]
la question reprend pour l'essentiel
l'intervention de Jean-Claude Tissot
vous vous en doutez mais Daniel grémilli
au début de son de son intervention
rappelait que l'enjeu était de cette
nomination était d'abord de donner un
cap à EDF qui entre nous en manque
cruellement mais quel cap allez vous
donner parce que la question pour moi
c'est celle là est-ce que vous allez
vous inscrire dans la poursuite de cette
dérive ultralibérale
de cette belle maison dont vous dites
qu'elle a fait parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle a fait la fierté des
femmes et des hommes qui l'ont façonné
et qui nous a amené dans une situation
dans lequel nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui vous serez vous
mandatés pour faire de ce très belle
maison
l'outil stratégique au cœur de la
reconquête de notre souveraineté
énergétique parce que
pouvant se positionner sur des enjeux un
moyen et long terme
et puis c'est vrai que votre passé de
dirigeant d'entreprises
très libérale et la politique libérale
ne plaide pas
en faveur voilà
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Raymond je n'ai pas compris sur quel
mandat du gouvernement repose la
candidature que vous briguez
quel est votre projet en réalité
organisationnelle notamment est-ce qu'on
reste dans un groupe complètement
intégré est-ce que le EDF pour le
nouveau nucléaire c'est l'objet d'une
filialisation particulière quel est
votre position votre appréciation du du
projet Hercule et grand EDF qui a qui a
suivi voilà comment vous situez par
rapport à ça en matière économique et
financière je voudrais savoir
quelle mesure vous envisagez pour
redresser la trajectoire financière et
bilancielle de l'entreprise qui est très
très préoccupante vous avez parlé de la
reine vous allez dire ce que vous en
pensez dans l'hypothèse dans l'hypothèse
qui qui n'est pas certaine mais qui est
possible ou la reine ne serait pas
supprimée qu'est-ce que vous faites
et en matière en matière tarifaire
est-ce que votre idée est de faire
d'aller vers des tarifs
premièrement en compte les coûts de
production complet à long terme du mix
et énergétique national
en matière de gouvernance un moment
donné il a été question de gouvernance
dual de DFE avec un président et un
directeur général comment vous vous
situez par rapport à ça
étant appelé à se prononcer pour un
poste une fonction de PDG ou de
président qui serait dotés par la suite
d'une fonction de directeur général ou
le contraire voilà et en matière de
financement du nouveau nucléaire dernier
point il est important
comment le financez-vous dans le
contexte actuel est-ce que vous passez
par exemple par des sociétés de projets
spécifiques de financement spécifique
qui remettrai évidemment en cause
l'intégrité où elle intégrité
du groupe tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui je vous remercie merci
Estrosi ça sonne qui se trouve ici et
ensuite Daniel salmon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Raymond deux
questions très courtes le gouvernement a
levé l'interdiction de publicité pour
les offres vendues au tarif réglementés
comme l'offre tempo de DF jusqu'à quand
cette mesure exceptionnelle était en
vigueur et combien quels sont vos
projections de souscription
d'abonnés dans les prochains mois et la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie a
lancé une enquête sur des fraudes à la
reine de certains fournisseurs qui
gonflent leur portefeuille clients pour
bénéficier de plus large quotas
d'électricité nucléaire a pris cassé
comment le groupe EDF entendit de faire
valoir ses droits devant la justice
merci beaucoup Dominique Daniel salmon
qui se trouve là-bas et ensuite Joël
l'abbé on fait un groupe et merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur Raymond le groupe
EDF est très largement endetté 60 70
milliards la reine est souvent montrée
du doigt ma question concerne le prix de
du nucléaire historique à combien
évaluez-vous le mégawater réel et non
pas fictif du mégawater de du nucléaire
historique la filière nucléaire vous le
savez à de nombreux maillons faibles
en particulier on peut parler en ce
moment de des piscines qui sont remplies
à bord pouvez-vous nous faire un point
sur ce sur ce maillon très important
votre équivalent italien
investi prévoit d'investir
dans une giga usine de panneaux
photovoltaïques que est-ce que EDF
compte en boitier le pas de NL et dans
ce cas comment compte-t-il intégrer
notre petite filière photovoltaïque qui
se meurt celle de celle de Photowatt je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup Daniel joël Labbé et
ensuite Anne-Catherine Loisier merci
madame la Présidente deux questions
rapides vous n'avez pas évoqué la
production d'énergie à partir
d'hydrogène
elle semble pourtant une filière
d'avenir dans la mesure où elle est
produite à partir de d'énergie
renouvelable je souhaiterais votre point
de vue là dessus et les moyens à mettre
dans la recherche parce que cette
recherche n'est pas encore abouti
seconde question vous avez beaucoup
parlé de production d'énergie sur votre
coeur de métier mais je ne vous ai pas
entendu parler ou nous ne vous avons pas
entendu parler de sobriété énergétique
vous vendez de l'énergie donc votre rôle
c'est de vendre et la sobriété fait en
sorte que vous vous vendiez le moins
possible
ce qui fait le ma conclusion j'aurais
aimé vous entendre parler plutôt
d'usagers que de clients je vous
remercie
très bien Anne Catherine Loisier ensuite
Evelyne Renaud de merabethi Madame la
présente monsieur merci beaucoup pour
cette présentation en fait je dirais que
vous avez partagé des constats sur
lesquels je pense qu'on se retrouve tous
mais on reste un petit peu sur notre fin
sur la stratégie effectivement à venir
voilà une fois qu'on a fait ces constats
comment ne pas retomber dans les écueils
et voilà quand les difficultés qu'on a
pu constater les choix qui nous ont
amené là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui
juste deux petites questions pratiques
vous n'avez pas je crois parler en fait
de la problématique de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée donc comment allez-vous
répondre à ce défi majeur et par contre
vous avez évoqué le numérique
électricité numérique le pilotage
numérique je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord sur l'intérêt de l'outil par
contre quand on dit numérique
aujourd'hui surtout dans un domaine
stratégique énergétique on dit aussi
vulnérabilité on le voit dans le
contexte de la guerre du crâne avec les
émissions de la Russie sur un certain
nombre de dispositifs donc voilà comment
comptez-vous ces risques majeurs
si beaucoup Anne-Catherine Evelyne
Renaud garabéeian qui est tout au fond à
droite merci Monsieur Raymond deux
questions je souhaitais vous interroger
sur les cyberattaques que peut subir ou
subi EDF dans les semaines à venir comme
l'a dit ma collègue le contexte des
tensions qui existent sur le secteur de
l'énergie et de la crise géopolitique
avec la Russie pourrait offrir de
nouvelles opportunités aux attaquants
qu'ils soient éthiques ou criminels que
ce soit pour l'appât du gain ou bien
pour des réseaux sociaux d'objectifs
stratégiques comment est-ce que est-ce
que vous envisagez d'importer la
connaissance que vous aviez dans votre
ancienne activité chez Schneider
Electric et une deuxième question la
semaine dernière nous avons auditionné
la ministre de la transition énergétique
avec laquelle nous avons discuté sur la
géothermie elle mène nous a indiqué
qu'elle envisageait de développer
considérablement ce secteur
sous-exploité je voulais savoir ce que
vous envisager par la suite de faire
avec la filière dalka notamment avec les
50 installations géométrie existants en
France merci
président à droite dans les territoires
ultramarins ou l'énergie solaire est
prédominante le gouvernement a décidé de
revoir à la baisse le coût de rachat de
l'énergie injectée dans le réseau
occasionneur ralentissement du
développement du photovoltaïque compte
tenu du coût d'approche du matériel et
de l'étroitesse du marché par ailleurs
un projet d'installation d'une turbine
de production d'électricité couplée à
notre usine d'incinération des ordures
tarde à se réaliser le ministre de
l'Outre-mer lors de sa visite à
Saint-Barthélémy le 16 octobre dernier a
annoncé qu'il plaiderait pour un coût de
rachat d'énergie par EDF autour de 350
euros du mégawater quel est votre avis
sur ce sujet seriez-vous favorable à le
défendre auprès de la creux
merci Micheline Patricia schilland je
suis Rémy quel serait votre besoin en
tant que PDG d'EDF pour accompagner les
aider les collectivités locales face à
la hausse des prix de l'électricité
après quels sont vos perspectives pour
la Business unique de DF à savoir EDF
Seix qui travaille dans les zones non
interconnectées corps outre-mer
île du Ponant pour accélérer le
déploiement des ENR et atteindre
l'autonomie énergétique merci
merci beaucoup Patricia Rémi Cardon et
pour terminer Laurence
merci madame la Présidente question très
simple que pensez-vous de la stratégie
de l'État français avec la facture un
peu salée des 24 milliards qui comprend
effectivement
10 milliards de manéganistes sur les
recettes fiscales pour l'électricité 6
milliards de dépenses pour le gaz et
7,5 milliards de remise à la pompe pour
le carburant en réalité qualificité
derrière si on y regarde avec ce chiffre
de 24 milliards quand le fait que l'État
finance donc autant un couple retraité
qui chauffe sa piscine et qu'un
travailleur modeste qui maintient sa
température de son salon à 19 degrés
pour le début de l'hiver de plus dans le
Bouclier tarifaire il y a une réelle
difficulté il y a des grands oubliés si
je parle notamment des entreprises et
des collectivités qui n'ont plus accès
au tarif réglementé en suite à
l'application des règles européennes de
la concurrence donc quel est votre
feuille de route sur ce bouclier
tarifaire et qu'est-ce que vous proposez
pour redresser la barre
[Musique]
la présidente vous avez dit dans votre
propos luminaire Monsieur Raymond que la
situation financière oblige EDF
effectivement à voir une stratégie sur
les investissements mais aussi une
vision sur la régulation des prix comme
vous êtes un observateur extérieur
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui quel conseil
stratégique avez-vous
posé comme conditions au gouvernement
pour cette régulation des prix et pour
pouvoir permettre à EDF de se développer
sur ses investissements
voilà Monsieur Raymond l'ensemble des
questions certaines sont très précises
certaines sont plus stratégiques je vais
vous laisser y répondre certaines sont
peut-être pas de votre voilà domaine de
compétence mais je vous laisse y
répondre merci beaucoup mesdames madame
la Présidente merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices je
vais essayer de répondre toutes vos
questions
et j'espère que vous ne m'en voudrez pas
si j'en oublie un peu mais de toute
façon je reviendrai vers vous avec des
réponses plus précises
alors je vais les reprendre dans l'ordre
si vous le voulez bien alors Monsieur
Tissot me demande ceci
si mon passé détermine mon avenir
alors Monsieur Tissot j'ai fait beaucoup
de choses comme tout le monde j'ai pas
fait que des bonnes choses
mais il y a une chose qui est claire
c'est que tout ce que j'ai fait je l'ai
fait avec le souhait le sentiment de de
trouver les voisins pour les entreprises
avec lesquelles j'étais en relation ou
dont j'avais la charge de développer
leur activité ça a toujours été
ma direction ça a toujours été ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a déterminé j'ai été formé
pour ça j'ai eu des mentors comme
Francis Maya que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure grand industriel qui m'a
expliqué qui m'ont appris comment
comment fonder le développement d'une
entreprise et comment ensuite travailler
pour trouver les voies financières et
techniques pour le développement de ces
entreprises et dans certaines
circonstances ça amène à aller chercher
des actionnaires diversifiés dans
d'autres ça peut amener à travailler
avec un seul actionnaire et ben il se
trouve que cette fois-ci je vais
travailler de ce actionnaire le plus
probablement puisque c'est le projet de
l'état de devenir actionnaire à 100%
c'est un actionnaire de long terme et je
pense que dans les circonstances du
moment qui sont la relance d'un plan
d'investissement qui nécessite une
vision de long terme je pense que
c'était un moment
utile pour l'entreprise d'avoir un
actionnaire de long terme qui permet
d'être son interlocuteur pour aborder ce
nouveau cycle de vie de l'entreprise
monsieur gay
vous vous m'interpellez sur les sms je
vous remercie ah pardon monsieur
excusez-moi j'ai parfois j'ai du mal à
reporter au fermeture
SMS alors je crois beaucoup je vais pas
faire un trop long développement sur la
nouvelle filière européen parce que ça
le mériterait il y a beaucoup de leçons
à tirer des premiers prototypes qui ont
été construits sur les deux dernières
décennies avec des difficultés
industrielles difficultés de chantier
etc je pense que c'est c'est le son sont
en train d'être tirer ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que EDF sur sur les
leçons apprises à la fois le petit
Lieutaud flamants vilink les points pour
lancer pour se préparer à lancer
maintenant la deuxième génération de
paix avec un objectif
d'industrialisation mais je crois qu'il
est souhaitable d'avoir dans cette
filière comme dans d'autres un
portefeuille de solution qui permet de
s'adapter aux besoins des clients et des
pays donc pour la France comme pour
l'étranger même si les SMS sont pas au
même niveau de développement bien sûr
que la filière EPR 2 pour la France
comme pour l'étranger je pense qu'il est
souhaitable d'avoir cette filière SMR
qui bénéficie vous l'avez dit du
savoir-faire récurrent accumuler
notamment dans la filière propulsion
navale pour avoir un portefeuille
d'options pour servir à la fois le pays
et les prospects à l'export avec
différents types de puissance et
différents types de réacteurs donc
évidemment je me consacrerai à faire en
sorte que ce projet aille de l'avant
alors ensuite j'ai oublié du coup de ce
que m'avait dit Monsieur gay mais votre
position sur l'arène et sur la
structuration
[Musique]
je crois il me semble pourtant avoir été
clair sur ce que j'avais dit sur la
reine s'il accepte un mécanisme à bout
de souffle qui certes a permis de
stabiliser
les prix en tout cas de préserver les
clients français
d'une hausse excessive de prix dans
l'environnement actuel et pour autant
évidemment le deuxième objectif de la
reine qui était de créer une concurrence
réelle n'est pas atteint puisqu'il n'y a
pas d'investissement en dehors de en
dehors d'EDF clairement et donc il faut
réformer ce système j'ai été assez clair
est-ce que à ce stade n'étant pas encore
dans l'entreprise je peux vous dire
exactement comme il faut le faire non
c'est trop tôt j'ai besoin de travailler
dessus avec les équipes d'EDF mais je
sais bien le l'orientation que je
prendrais dans mes discussions avec les
pouvoirs publics madame
madame Berthet voilà vous m'interpellier
sur
les 84% et sur l'hydroélectricité donc
sur les 84% je pense que vraiment nous
sommes dans une phase dans laquelle EDF
doit être capable de tirer à long terme
dépasser évidemment les difficultés du
moment sur des difficultés opératives et
reprendre un niveau de production élevé
mais être capable de regarder à long
terme et pour cela avoir un seul
actionnaire ça simplifie la capacité de
regarder à long terme
sur l'hydroélectricité vous vous l'avez
tout à fait justement souligné
je ne connais pas encore tous les
détails du dispositif des différentes
options juridiques techniques etc qui
sont nécessaires à la pérennisation de
l'activité hydroélectrique cette
pérennisation est nécessaire elle
correspond à la volonté des pouvoirs
public de la volonté du gouvernement
exprimé également donc je travaillerai
sur les modalités techniques précises le
plus rapidement possible pour trouver un
accord sur les dispositions qui
permettent EDF de poursuivre son
activité hydroélectrique et donner la
perspective de long terme là aussi dans
les relations avec les collectivités
locales qui sont évidemment un
partenaire absolument essentiel de cette
activité
ensuite monsieur buis vous m'avez
mauvais demandé comment on pouvait
passer de l'introduction en Bourse à la
renationalisation
il faut en toute chose un peu de
flexibilité puis avec l'âge on finit par
mûrir et et par considérer que voilà il
y a pas de direction absolue et que ce
qui compte c'est de faire avancer
l'entreprise voilà donc c'est dans cet
état d'esprit que je m'inscris sur la
relance du nucléaire sur la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre vous avez tout à fait
raison bon il y a déjà des mesures qui
sont engagées et ça couvre bien toutes
les chaînes c'est le problème c'est pas
de trouver que des ingénieurs faut
trouver des soudeurs et un soudeur
nucléaire ça prend trois ans à form donc
on parle bien de métier de métier
industriel alors c'est une problématique
que je connais bien dans mon métier
actuel parce que trouver des
électriciens en France je peux vous dire
c'est le même problème donc donc dans
mon métier actuel nous faisons l'effort
de former
je crois une dizaine de milliers
d'électriciens chaque année en France
pour que ce métier attire et ce métier
perdu je sais que dans l'industrie
navale par exemple dont j'étais
administrateur
l'industrie navale a pris l'initiative
de lancer toute une série d'écoles de
formation à tous les niveaux vous voyez
qualifiés techniciens et ingénieurs
parce que c'est indispensable donc le
nucléaire a pris la même direction au
travers du gifen notamment et je
soutiendrai ces mesures et même j'en
prendrai la tête parce que je pense que
le monde professionnel a besoin de voir
toute la filière mobilier a besoin de
voir le PDG d'EDF à la tête de ces
sujets là sont en quoi il y a pas de
filière industrielle et s'il n'y a pas
de filière industrielle on empile les
délais et le temps est notre principal
ennemi donc dans tout ça
madame Artigues
vous m'avez posé la question sur les
concessions hydroélectriques donc j'ai
besoin de travailler sur le sujet comme
je l'ai comme je viens de l'expliquer
mais c'est évidemment un élément
absolument clé du programme stratégique
d'EDF et de la volonté gouvernementale
de pérenniser cette activité au sein de
DF donc je travaillerai dans cette
direction je peux pas vous donner toutes
les modalités aujourd'hui parce que je
ne les ai pas encore mais ça fera partie
de mes sujets de travail immédiat bien
sûr
madame Jacquet Jacquet excusez-moi je
suis désolé
vous m'avez interpellé sur le coup pour
les ménages
alors c'est un sujet délicat évidemment
parce que finalement nous sommes dans
une situation dans laquelle depuis 20
ans
les 58 réacteurs nous permettent d'avoir
une énergie très compétitive
et il faut que nous abordions maintenant
ainsi que dans lequel nous préparons
l'avenir et dans ce site qui prépare
l'avenir tout le monde va devoir y
mettre du sien l'entreprise on est en
performante ça c'est une partie de mon
travail c'est même l'essentiel de mon
travail si vous le voulez bien
ensuite
la nation dans le sens où la nation
contribue au renouvellement de cette
capacité mais les clients ou les usagers
comme vous préférez évidemment devront
participer et je rappelle que le parc de
58 réacteurs il a été financé sans aucun
ou avec très très peu ou pratiquement
sans aucun financement public et donc ce
sont les clients qui l'ont qui l'ont
financé ils l'ont financé simplement en
évitant je crois que ce qui est le plus
important c'est d'éviter les
fluctuations complètement de gérer des
prix c'est ça qui est totalement
destructeur mais le fait que nous
finantions ou que les clients financent
le coût complet y compris le cyclaval et
je fais le lien avec votre deuxième
question qui est le traitement des
déchets ça c'est une nécessité pour la
pérennité de la filière donc oui
naturellement je suis très attentif au
sujet de Laval et au sujet du traitement
des déchets je ne connais pas encore
tous les éléments des projets parce que
il y a beaucoup de choses à apprendre et
à redécouvrir ou à découvrir quand on
est encore à l'extérieur de l'entreprise
mais c'est bien un des piliers
essentiels de la pérennité de la filière
et c'est bien sur l'ensemble du cycle y
compris des constructions que je
travaillerai avec les équipes de DF et
les entreprises et les instituts ou
organisation publique qui travaille
dessus pour nous assurer de la cohérence
de l'ensemble de la filière sur
l'ensemble du cycle
si je mélange les feuilles en plus ça va
pas alors madame
vous m'avez demandé quel serait ma
méthode pour prendre en compte les
résultats de la concertation
c'est une excellente question mais
bon la concertation est elle concerne à
la fois les pouvoirs publics bien sûr et
l'entreprise donc le résultat de la
concertation il va devoir être pris en
compte par le gouvernement et également
par l'entreprise donc la seule réponse
que je puisse vous faire à ce stade
c'est que c'est évidemment un des sujets
essentiels que je vais discuter avec le
gouvernement pour prendre en
considération le résultat de la
concertation et voir quelles sont les
suites à donner mais ça peut pas être
une prise en compte uniquement par
l'entreprise c'est ça que je veux vous
dire
[Musique]
Monsieur du
pardon excuse-moi j'ai peur de du plomb
voilà j'ai peur d'écorcher les noms donc
ah oui monsieur Duplomb qui m'avait
interpellé
d'autres qui m'a dit qu'il me donnerait
sa voix et je lui en suis reconnaissant
au début donc je vous en remercie
l'exemple que vous citez est évidemment
saisissant évidemment saisissant je n'ai
pas à l'heure où nous parlons la
solution
je sais qu'il y a des situations comme
ceci ça ne me satisfait pas je sais que
DF travail main dans la main avec le
gouvernement pour trouver un maximum de
solutions possibles et il y en a qui
sortent tous les jours donc j'ai même du
mal à les suivre à ce stade parce que
voilà ça veut dire quand même la
dimension critique du sujet et bien
prise en compte par tout le monde voilà
je n'ai pas de baguette magique a
fortiorer parce que je ne suis pas
encore dans l'entreprise mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'évidemment ça
sera ma préoccupation immédiate
après EDF doit travailler dans les
règles de marché qui lui ont fixés mais
on voilà je ferai avec le gouvernement
tout ce qu'on peut voilà moi mes clients
d'aujourd'hui sont dans le monde entier
des PME donc notamment donc je sais ce
que c'est
merci beaucoup
monsieur Menouville mais non-ville
pardon mais non il est excusez-moi
déploiement sur le territoire des
différences de paires bon là aussi là
aussi ça relève de la concertation je
pense évidemment avec avec le
gouvernement avec les autorités locales
avec les collectivités
il y a des problématiques d'autorisation
naturellement il faudra qu'il faudra
prendre en considération
là aussi j'insiste sur la dimension
temps
je j'ai rappelé la performance de nos
anciens 58 réacteurs en 20 ans
je ne pense pas que nous soyons capables
aujourd'hui en tant que nation de
déployer 58 réacteurs en 20 ans pour des
raisons industrielles et ça ça me
regarde largement avec toute la filière
mais aussi pour des raisons de ce que
nous sommes en tant que nation en termes
de capacité à construire et donc là
dessus j'aurais besoin de tout le monde
vraiment pour pour être capable de
répondre à l'exigence de nouvelles
capacités qui sont nécessaires pour
accompagner l'électrification et le
renouvellement du parc donc je sais
qu'il y a des travaux qui sont en cours
et que vous y avez passé d'ailleurs une
partie de la nuit si j'ai bien compris
sur les énergies renouvelables mais ça
touche tous les domaines et évidemment
le nucléaire aussi
vous m'avez parlé de six géo c'est un
projet que je connais seulement un peu à
ce stade mais qui est absolument
critique bien sûr et donc je ferai tout
le nécessaire pour le découvrir dans les
détails et pour être certain que pour
ceux qui concerne EDF nous y
participions de façon active
madame blatrix
vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'international et surinkley point alors
il est un projet très important pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'il
est important pour le Royaume-Uni dans
l'équilibre futur du parc nucléaire du
Royaume-Uni important pour EDF qui est
un gros acteur au Royaume-Uni et
évidemment de la même façon que nous
avons besoin de préparer l'avenir en
France EDF étant un acteur important au
Royaume-Uni nous avons besoin de
préparer l'avenir au Royaume-Uni est
aussi important pour la filière parce
que inclipoint arrive en termes
d'activité à un moment de creux
d'activité et quand vous n'avez pas
d'activité dans une filière ben vous
détruisez la filière industrielle donc
les points est très important de ce
point de vue là aussi et donc évidemment
je m'y rendrai et je suis vrai le projet
de près comme tous les projets il peut
avoir des aléas et des difficultés et
nous y ferons face et nous les
relèverons
ensuite la relation avec l'Allemagne
veut interroger sur la relation avec
l'Allemagne je pensais un point très
important et nous le voyons d'ailleurs
dans les discussions quasi quotidiennes
qui qui animent aujourd'hui les
discussions intergouvernementales et
européennes je crois vraiment et je
connais ça correspond à l'expression du
gouvernement et du président de la
République nous devons construire un
nouveau consensus énergétique avec
l'Allemagne il y a des divergences elles
sont claires mais je c'est vraiment très
important pour l'avenir du marché
électrique européen que ces divergences
soient exprimés à planning pour que nous
arrivions à créer un nouveau consensus
européen sur l'électricité notamment
mais sur l'énergie plus généralement
monsieur
meriou
vous m'avez demandé que si j'arrivais
avec
un plan où vous avez dit ultra libéral
je crois
et je suis je me souviens d'un de mes
collègues qui m'avaient dit je suis
surtout ultra humaniste c'est c'est ça
qui me définit mieux que ultralibéral je
crois à l'entreprise il y a pas d'autres
là-dessus je crois la réussite de
l'entreprise et je crois que je crois
que l'entreprise se développe par les
projets qu'elle forme elle-même et
qu'elle conduit à la réussite par sa
capacité à les mener à bien voilà voilà
ce à quoi je crois je n'arrive pas avec
un plan qui met défini j'arrive avec le
mandat de faire réussir EDF voilà mon
mandat
[Musique]
vous m'avez posé la question de mon
mandat aussi donc je pense que je peux
vous faire à peu près la même réponse
je n'ai pas l'habitude de raisonner sur
les organisations avant d'avoir raisonné
sur l'objectif je pense que c'est un
raisonnement qui est à l'envers donc
ce que j'ai essayé de vous expliquer
dans mon propolisaire c'est que ma
vision d'un opérateur électrique
qui réussit c'est c'est quelqu'un c'est
un une entreprise qui réussit à avoir
trois métiers fondamentaux qui sont le
développement de solution pour les
clients
une production diversifiée et les
réseaux et c'est bien dans dans la
capacité d'avoir ces trois métiers
fondamentaux fonctionnant en synergie au
sein d'EDF que je pense fonder la
réussite future de DF
il y avait beaucoup d'éléments
mais
la Reine je crois que j'ai supprimé
qu'est-ce
qui se passe et
la question
du
redressementiels de l'entreprise alors
sur la reine je crois avoir répondu à
certains de vos collègues sur le
financement du nouveau nucléaire
notamment il y a du travail à faire il
faut inscrire financement du nouveau
nucléaire dans une perspective de long
terme qui concerne bien sûr EDF au
premier chef mais qui doit permettre
d'avoir cette vision de long terme qui
est indispensable au cycle du nucléaire
donc j'ai besoin de travailler je
reviendrai vous voir une fois que
j'aurai une
des modalités qui sont qui sont arrêtés
et qui sont partagés naturellement avec
le gouvernement et probablement la
Commission européenne aussi madame
Estrosi ça sonne vous m'avez interrogé
sur la publicité tempo jusqu'à quand je
ne sais pas
je suis très heureux d'avoir reçu
moi-même la proposition d'adhérer à
tempo ce que je vais faire bien sûr vous
m'avez interrogé sur les fraudes à la
reine qui m'interpellent autant que vous
clairement je pensais pas des c'est un
des signes que la reine est un
dispositif qui fondamentalement ne
fournit qu'une option gratuite un
certain nombre de commercialisateurs qui
peuvent le cas échéant même en abusé
donc nous suivrons attentivement
les résultats de l'enquête de la creux
et le cas échéant évidemment
je regarderai ce qu'il convient de faire
d'un point de vue juridique de la part
de DF
[Musique]